Think the Inquisitor Marrok is the next big
thing in Star Wars? Think again. Turns out,
this franchise has got a real bad guy problem.
The Star Wars franchise has developed a
nasty habit of wasting cool characters
before they've realized their full potential.
If a villainous character is the brooding,
silent type, chances are they'll be
disposed of pretty quickly. Unfortunately,
this trend has continued with Ahsoka, which kills
off the mysterious Inquisitor Marrok in Episode 4.
The unfortunate moment occurs when Ahsoka
Tano slices the Inquisitor's midriff during
a chaotic lightsaber battle in a forest.
Afterward, Marrok disappears into thin air,
presumably to never return again. The green
smoke that accompanies his disappearance also
suggests that Marrok is a zombie who was
created by the Nightsisters of Dathomir,
which should end the theory that he's
actually Ezra Bridger in disguise.
While the nature of Marrok's death serves
to enhance the lore of the Galaxy, Far,
Far Away, his exit from Ahsoka
feels a little premature. He's
essentially this series' version of the
original Boba Fett and Captain Phasma,
both of whom also suffered underwhelming
stories in the grand scheme of things.
So does Star Wars have an issue when it
comes to creating compelling arcs for its
coolest mysterious characters? Let's look
at the history, starting with the bounty
hunter Boba Fett. His first appearance in
The Empire Strikes Back led us to believe
that he was going to be a formidable villain
— but he turned out to be pretty much useless,
as evidenced by his anti-climactic fall
into the Sarlacc pit in Return of the Jedi.
"Laugh it up, fuzzball."
Similarly, the Star Wars sequel trilogy
introduces Captain Phasma as a powerful
Stormtrooper who seems like she's
going to be a constant thorn in
Finn and Rey's sides. Unfortunately, Phasma is
killed off rather abruptly in The Last Jedi.
Of course, The Book of Boba Fett series on
Disney+ and the Phasma novel add more depth
to their respective characters' backstories. But
that doesn't mean that they weren't wasted from
the get-go, and it remains to be seen if Marrok
will get his own expanded story down the line.
While Ahsoka presents Marrok as a serious
threat, his death in Episode 4 means that
the show has missed an opportunity to
dig into his origins. His association
with Morgan Elsbeth and the Daughters of
Dathomir implies that he's a Nightbrother,
a society whose history hasn't really been
covered in great detail in the live-action
realm of the Star Wars franchise. Everyone loves
a little mystery, of course, but the end of
Marrok has robbed fans of the perfect vehicle
to explore this side of the Star Wars galaxy.
Moreover, Marrok is an Inquisitor, meaning
that he was once part of an elite death squad
and an heir to the Sith. While they aren't
full Sith per se, Inquisitors are perfectly
capable of using elements of the Force to
inflict damage on their opponents. Sadly,
Ahsoka doesn't give this villain an
opportunity to really showcase his
abilities outside of a couple of fight scenes.
Ahsoka eliminates him with relative ease too,
which just adds to the notion that Marrok
was created to be a throwaway character.
Granted, it's possible that Ahsoka will unveil
more Marrok-esque assassins down the line; Morgan,
Baylan Skoll, and Shin Hati need soldiers to aid
them in their quest to find Grand Admiral Thrawn,
after all. That said, Marrok is an inherently
cool character who got fans speculating,
and losing him has brought an end
to some interesting discourse.
And Marrok's death has certainly spurred some fans
to share their views. One Twitter user writes:
"Alas, poor Marrok. We barely knew ye."
Another echoed that sentiment,
stating that the character had
lots of potential to grow and develop. They wrote:
"I think a former Inquisitor turned mercenary
could be a super cool recurring character
in Star Wars lore. Potential for a new
Boba Fett level of mysterious badass."
That said, while many fans were sad to say
goodbye to the Inquisitor, one Redditor
believes that Marrok's death is actually quite
fitting for someone of his ilk. They wrote:
"Can't escape the Inquisitor tradition of
going out like a punk against Ahsoka I guess."